okay today I'm going to talk to you
about interdependence organisms that
means living things depend on each other
for things like food and shelter in
order to survive and this is what in
interdependence means it basically means
if there's a change in a population of
one species it will have a knock-on
effect on another species now to
illustrate this I'm going to draw a
simple food chain so first of all at the
bottom I've just drawn a producer in
this case it's grass right here I'm
drawing a very poor picture of a
caterpillar and just above that again I
apologize for my drawings this is a
picture of a bird now all this food
change shows is the grass is eaten by
the caterpillar and caterpillars are
eaten by birds now let's show how all of
these organisms are interdependent upon
one another so let's imagine if a hunter
shot all of these birds what would
happen to the number of caterpillars
because few of the caterpillars are
being eaten by the birds there'd be an
increase in the caterpillar population
if there's an increase in the
caterpillar population there's going to
be more caterpillars to eat the grass so
they'll be less grass available
similarly let's just imagine another
example of interdependence so let's
imagine now instead all of the grass
died because there was a drought so
there wasn't enough water for the grass
to grow so if there's no grass then
that's going to hugely impact the
caterpillar population and there'll be
fewer caterpillars well eventually
there'd be no caterpillars it's all of
them got nothing to eat if there's no
caterpillars then all of the birds will
die out as well so interdependence shows
it demonstrates how these different
organisms depend upon one another their
numbers influence each other now there's
just a couple more things that we need
to look at in terms of interdependence
one word we need to know is parasitism
which is basically to do with parasites
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
demonstrate what a parasite
I'm just gonna do a picture of a dog and
we are going to think of an example of a
parasite because an example of a
parasite is a flea which is on the body
of a dog
so again apologies for my not-so-great
drawing of a dog there we go now in a
parasitic relationship there are two
different organisms one in this context
the dog is the host so living off the
host is a parasite in this context it's
a flea so there's a little flea which is
drinking the blood of the dog now in
this context the flea is the parasite
now in a parasitic relationship between
two organisms it's only beneficial for
one of the organisms it's only
beneficial for the parasite so parasitic
relationships is only good for one of
the two organisms in organisms involved
now the other type of relationship we
need to know about apart from parasitism
is mutualism and a really nice example
of a mutualistic relationship is the
relationship between plants and bees so
just take one second to draw these
plants and then over here is going to be
my B now unlike a parasitic relationship
where it's only good it's only
beneficial for one of the organisms in a
mutualistic relationship it's good for
both of the organisms so in this
particular example the benefit that the
bees get is nectar I Eve food from the
plants so as the beads go onto the
plants they get their food and then they
go to the next plant the benefit for the
plants is pollen basically stays on the
on the B on its legs and on it's on it's
on
and when it goes to the other plans it
transfers the pollen allowing the plants
to reproduce so the big difference
between a parasitic relationship and a
mutualistic relationship is a minute
mutualistic relationship is beneficial
for both organisms involved not just one
so that guy's shows interdependence
it shows how organisms affect have an
effect on each other and that effect on
each other and that relationship between
each other is called interdependence
thank you